there's a verse which is very famous
most people who are have been in contact
with christianity
have heard it
and uh you know if you if you met people
who is trying someone who's trying to
convert you often they will cite you
this verse it is from the book of romans
for the wages of sin is death
but the gift of god is eternal life in
christ jesus our lord so what i would
like to do is i would like to look at
that verse in its basic concepts in the
book of romans and look
at how this the structure that saint
paul traces for us in uh in the book of
romans and especially in this section
can really help us understand the way
that
symbolic structures work the way that
things hold together in the world and
that ultimately what saint paul says is
fractally true at every level and isn't
just a question of morality
or of uh dying and going to heaven and
all that kind of stuff and so hopefully
we can have a fruitful
examination of this
[Music]
passage this is jonathan pedro
welcome to the symbolic world
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so i'm going to read uh part of the text
maybe not the not the entire text it's
from roman 6 i will start at verse 15.
you can read around it if you want to
get more context than what i'm going to
uh to say
and so i'll start with 14 actually
so saint paul is talking about becoming
free from sin and becoming attached to
grace becoming slaves of god becoming
slaves of grace and no longer being
slaves of sin
and so he says for sin shall no longer
be your master because you are not under
the law but under grace
what then shall we sin because we are
not under the law but under grace by no
means don't you know that when you offer
yourselves to someone as obedient slaves
you are slaves to the one you obey
whether you are slaves to sin which
leads to death or to obedience which
leads to righteousness but thanks be to
god
that though you used to be slaves to sin
you have come to obey from your heart
the pattern of teaching that has now
claimed your allegiance
you have been set free from sin and have
become slaves to righteousness i'm using
an example from everyday life because of
your human limitations
just as you used to offer yourselves as
slaves to impurity and to ever
increasing wickedness so now you offer
yourselves as slaves to righteousness
leading to holiness when you were slaves
to sin you were free from the control of
righteousness what benefit did you reap
at that time from the things you are now
ashamed of those things result in death
but now you have been set free from sin
and have become slaves of god the
benefit you reap leads to holiness and
the result is eternal life for the wages
of sin is death but the gift of god is
eternal life in christ jesus our lord
and so obviously i'm not going to go
through all the implications of this
text we're going to look at the manner
in which this text connects to
the basic symbolic structure that i
often talk about let's say the way in
which things hold together in
hierarchies in the world of course this
does not take away from you know the the
usual interpretation that you might hear
see in the church fathers um but
hopefully this will at least help those
people that follow my work kind of see
how it connects to what i what i'm
trying to explain to you
um so the
one of the things that saint paul is
doing of course in the book of romans is
he's distinguishing something like
law the law as a bunch of rules you
follow
from
allegiance or faith or attachment or
something which is more than just
following a bunch of rules which is
grasping
the higher reality that you're
participating in
and so a a this is not complicated it
sounds complicated it's not complicated
at all and so you could say that
if you grasp for example um
you know the the
the reason why the rules exist then
those rules become almost irrelevant
because you understand why the rules are
there and therefore you naturally
embody the the what the rule is trying
to capture right and so if you
understand you know why it is good to be
honest than to to care for your neighbor
you know because you love them and you
see the face of god in them and because
you see them as as you know
as brothers and sisters you know
then rules about you know not stealing
and not breaking into people's houses
and not doing all these things are going
to be irrelevant to you you know you
don't have to in a certain manner you
don't have to follow those rules
explicitly because the behavior that you
will have will implicitly flow from the
attachment to the higher ideal you know
and this is of course uh you know this
is of course the same for many things
that are even something like that or
technical you know if you understand
you know if you understand the purpose
of something you're making you will be
less bound by all the steps you're
making to do them so a chef for example
someone who's not very good at cooking
will follow recipes very strictly we'll
we'll read all the instructions we'll
put them but it's once you understand
cooking and you understand let's say
what it is you're trying to accomplish
in terms of taste in terms of experience
for the people then you don't really
need cookbooks so much anymore you might
look at them you know as a as a basic
guide but usually you you imbibe the
reason why you're making food and you've
kind of reached a level of attachment
and expertise that means that you don't
need the rules so much anymore and so
this is really what saint paul is
talking about but obviously talking
about it in terms of your own personal
life and in terms of the manner in which
you exist and so when you exist under
grace this is a way to understand it the
difference between existing under the
law and existing under grace when you
have captured the higher participation
then you
exist something like under grace you
don't have to follow a bunch of rules
you don't have to do a bunch of things
but but rather the things you do flow
from above they don't they don't just
exist below
and this is really
trying to help you understand this
notion of the hierarchy of beings you
know the diff i've talked about this
before which is the idea that faith is
this jump from the bunch of things you
need to do into the gestalt into the one
thing above
in in this hierarchy of beings that is
holding everything together and once you
grasp that and it really is it's
understanding to it's important to
understand that it's not just kind of
like a
an intellectual thought it really is a
grasping it is a an allegiance it is a
it is more like something akin to
uh let's say exactly the way saint paul
talks about it it is more something like
becoming us becoming a slave in the
sense
in the sense of being having your
allegiance to that thing and so if you
love something and you've submitted
yourself to it to it and you you you've
dedicated your allegiance to it then
like i said
you will naturally naturally will flow
from you the behaviors that are part of
it and saint paul is
it's really smart what he does is that
he is explaining to you that if you for
example like if you are have your
allegiance to sin that is if you have
your allegiance to something which
misses the mark to these parasitic
processes that we talk about a lot on
this channel these these behaviors and
these patterns of being that that think
that they have it all you know together
then you don't have to follow any laws
do you there are no laws you know there
aren't no laws to uh to let's say
overeating it's like you just are a a
slave to that pattern and your behavior
flows freely
from that slavery and so saint paul
obviously he says he says look i'm gonna
i'm gonna talk to you
in a way that
you can understand right because of the
weakness of your flesh but he's saying
it's kind of like that it's like the way
in which you are a slave to sin
and your behavior freely flows from that
slavery that's the way
that you are going to be a slave to god
that is if you attach yourself to god
and you then you live in grace and your
behavior will simply flow
from from from that uh from above let's
say
and so it might seem weird to people but
he's also trying to help you understand
that
this is it really is about submitting
yourself to the right principality and
entering into that principality it's not
so much about rules and about a bunch of
stuff you do
rules in a bunch of stuff you do and the
laws in the bible are useful they can
kind of help you gather things together
and sometimes they can help you see
dimly what it is that the rule is aiming
for but if you just follow the rules
then you're never going to
be transformed you're never going to
reach
you know all the elements below
don't give you that which is above right
all the elements of a pen of a pen or a
glass or a table or a team or whatever
none of them give you the reason the
reason is above you have you access it
through faith and then it flows down
into the behavior through grace and and
it's there's something natural about the
way that identity flows down from
in this hierarchy of beings um and
anybody who has uh experienced it will
will know the difference right you don't
you don't once you you kind of grasp
going upstairs and going downstairs you
don't have to break it down into all the
different behaviors you're doing but if
you're teaching a child let's say to go
upstairs at first you know you maybe you
will tell them like do this do that this
way to do it be careful of this be
careful of that and there's an
indefinite amount of things that you
could tell the child to do and what
you're hoping is that will kind of help
them see and once they grasp it
then you don't have to give them any
rules anymore they just do it naturally
and it flows from there
and so the way that saint paul presents
it it really is
to a certain extent the idea of
attachment and fruits and so what it is
that you're attached to will produce
fruits because they are bound you know
it really is like a tree that has an
identity that it's an apple tree or
whatever and that tree then naturally
will release its identity into these
these manifestations into the fruit and
this is what saint paul is these are all
the images that saint paul is trying to
help you understand and so he's saying
that
when you attach yourself to these
parasitic processes when you attach
yourself to death that is if you enter
into
uh you know a behavior that thinks that
it that acts only for itself you know
when you lie that's what you usually do
when you lie you usually sacrifice the
higher relationship you're having with
the person in front of you because in
order to get something and so the lie is
always parasitic because it is putting
you know whatever it is you want to get
as or even if it's just influence or you
know whatever it is higher than the
communion of you between the person
you're talking to and so once you enter
into that what it does because it's a
parasitic process
it doesn't have it's not sufficient it
doesn't have what it needs to ultimately
hold and it will devolve into what john
verveigh calls reciprocal narrowing
which is that
the behaviors of the sin
the self the kind of self devour because
they don't have enough to sustain you
and that and the fruit of that is death
that is what death is death is when
the aspects of of a being
start to let's say isolate themselves
from each other and start to to become
more independent from each other in a
way that is no longer unified and so
when you're a slave to sin what ends up
happening is your behavior start to
fragment and you can have you know
different obsessions you can have
you can swing from one side to the other
you can love and hate things at the same
time and you know these you'll compete
between these different passions that
have that you have within you and that
will slowly devolve into little
tyrannies and also into fragmentation of
yourself and so the
the wages of sin is death is a frac is a
description about how reality works but
the gift of god is eternal life in
christ jesus our lord that is
when you attach yourself
to christ that is when you attach
yourself to the incarnation we need to
attach yourself to the place where
heaven and earth meet to the place where
these
invisible purposes and identities
that come from heaven meet with earth
all the potentialities you know when you
you you
that is the that is when the gift of god
flows down from you that is when once
you when you're in that spot that is
when you have faith in christ then out
of that will flow
natural behaviors will flow grace will
throw things that won't feel like a
bunch of
of rules that that are that are binding
you but also will not produce
fruits that narrow and that are are
parasitic and will eat you up you know
as as you're kind of devolving and so
that's why it's experienced as a gift
and so you can understand it like
the identity of anything that you're
participating in is something like a
gift which flows from above it's
something that you can't get at the
level so you can't get at the level of
the behaviors you whether it's like a
like
i always use the same examples but like
if it's a sports team you know you can
learn to pass you can learn to to
dribble you can learn to sorry let's say
a basketball basketball team so you can
learn to pass you can learn to dribble
you can learn to run you can learn to to
to shoot but if you just have these bun
these bunch of things you never will get
the essence of the game the essence of
the game flows down like a gift from
heaven and it gives meaning to all these
behaviors that you're participating in
and so there is something of grace in
the manner in which
the purpose of basketball and the the
reality of basketball flows down into
all the elements that constitute it
so if you if you
miss the mark in basketball right if you
if you if you're not able to
to to to do this
reach that goal properly then you lose
right you lose the game you you you
don't win you know you know but if
you're able to truly let's say uh attach
yourself to the to the purpose then you
will have something like fullness of
life in not fullness of life
metaphysically but like fullness of
basketball right fullness of basketball
as you play it and this is what this is
what scales up all the way to the idea
of your very existence which is that
if you follow
if you don't realize what the law leads
to if you don't realize that the law is
there to kind of help you
see dimly to the purpose of things
and if you also let yours and if or if
you attach yourself to sin
then
you're not going to have fullness of
life but if you attach yourself to the
incarnation to the place where this
comes together in the heart let's say
through the heart through faith through
trust you know through love through all
these things that bind reality together
then what will flow down from heaven is
that it will flow down fullness of life
which will come down from the father
above and will fill everything that you
are part of with with meaning with
purpose with light um and so it is
really it really is a description of of
just basic description of reality and
the the paradox that saint paul is able
to
bring about is
it doesn't happen by doing a bunch of
things it happens by submitting yourself
to the highest principle by becoming a
slave to that which is above you the
right aspect that is above you and the
surprise of that is that it actually
fills you with freedom and this is
something that we you know that i've
talked about recently as well which is
that freedom doesn't just mean you do
whatever you want to do freedom can only
exist
as bound by a higher purpose right you
can't have if you drop someone in the
ocean you know and you say you're free
it's like okay
free free to do what right you're free
to just be there you know and to swim
around but if but if i give you a
purpose if i bind you to a higher
purpose then you can experience within
that purpose the parameters of of choice
the parameters of direction all of this
will appear
bound by higher purposes and so
that's also very important so the it is
a paradox but it's a paradox which is
not a not a contradiction it is that if
you if you are if you submit yourself to
a higher purpose then
in that slavery you will experience a
kind of freedom within those parameters
so if you become a slave to god if you
become a slave to the source of all
reality if you come become a slave to
the incarnation to christ that is the
place where
all the patterns and all of reality all
of potential meat in the heart then then
you will have fullness fullness of of
life
and it will appear to you as a gift so
hopefully this is not too abstract it's
not too too complicated i just wanted to
to help people see how saint paul
especially st paul is really uh really
talking about the nature of reality and
how reality works very often especially
when he uses the images of bodies and of
heads of a heart you know the
all of this idea of of a tree and fruits
all of these things he's really talking
about a very powerful
structure of how reality works so
hopefully this was helpful and will help
you at least uh
try to read saint paul with that
different vision and try to understand
it fractally and remember that it's not
just a technical question it does
obviously scale up into your very
transformation and your attachment to
god but you can also try to do it
fractally so you can see if i can
understand it at different levels of
reality then then i have a maybe a
little bit of a better grasp on what
saint paul is saying so thanks everybody
for your time and i'll talk to you very
soon
as you know the symbolic world is not
just a bunch of videos on youtube we are
also a podcast which you can find on
your uh usual podcast platform but we
also have a website with a blog and
several very interesting articles by
very intelligent people that have been
thinking about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects we also have a clips channel a
facebook group you know there's a whole
lot of ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and the
discussion of symbolism don't forget
that my brother matsuya wrote a book
called the language of creation which is
a very powerful synthesis of a lot of
the ideas that explore and so please
go ahead and explore this world you can
also participate by you know buying
things that i've designed t-shirts with
different designs on them and you can
also support this podcast and these
videos through paypal or through patreon
everybody who supports me has access to
an extra video a month and there are
also all kinds of other goodies and
tiers that you can get involved with so
everybody thank you again and thank you
for your support